back in ccsd still on the search for bus  drivers in the area a job fair was held  today to fill the 234 driver positions  needed across the district they've seen  a little over 50 people at the monthly  job events they say their current staff  though has been filling in for the roles  needed but it's been tough to make sure  students arrive to school on time and as  planned  our current staff is working hard to  make certain the kids are picked up and  kids are getting to school on time but  there's definitely some roadblocks to  that and  you know it would be helpful to be fully  staffed  ccsd has bumped up salaries to attract  more interest starting at just over 21  dollars an hour they have more job fairs  planned for july 9 and july 23rd